does the screenplay begin with the word
fade in doesn't begin with the word
faded and do you mean like should you
have fade in or not happy well this
writing began with the word fade in or
could someone actually begin part of it
in the middle I have an idea for a crux
of what I want to happen but I don't
have the book ending I don't have the
the finish part I don't have the
beginning yeah I think you can jump
around sure if if you have certain
scenes inside of you that you see
visually that are sort of the tent poles
for the story by all means write those
down and then write what works up to it
and what Springs off of them but if you
get to a certain place where you're only
writing what you love you're being a
little undisciplined you know at that
point you have to go alright I have to
start writing the scenes that I don't
know or don't love as well then start
from the beginning and start moving
toward those key scenes that you've
already written do you think a lot of
writers are undisciplined it seems like
writers of any of all the arts it seems
like writers are the most sort of
discipline the most heart of themselves
the most sort of reined in yeah a
fallacy I I don't find that they're
undisciplined but I I do think that we
all have little tricks that we play
where we write only things that we love
you know or or that we're good at you
know I've watched a lot of writers that
will write scene after scene and I'm
like yeah I know you can do this okay
where's that scene that's really hard
for you write that so it's not a
question of not being disciplined so
much as you know not wanting to be taken
to task for not not being wonderful
right away what for time wasting with
writers
aside from surfing the internet and
quote research what do you see as some
of the stumbling blocks to time
management well I think you just named
two two of them you know surfing the
internet and research right researched
is the most creative form of
procrastination where somebody goes no
wait I have to stop I really have to
look that up my my usual advice is no
write what you want and then find the
research that supports that story point
instead of the other way around but yeah
I think that that is the the place that
we all tend to convince ourselves that
we're actually working and we're not
we're surfing
you